[Música]
vamos con nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez amas de burrosa Buen día para
usted Buen día Ángela un temazo así lo
ha definido usted misma antes de salir
al aire así eliminó Estados Unidos los
gasoductos North Stream una
investigación de Samuel que es un
reconocido periodista de investigación y
reportero de guerra premio pulit será
además quien publicó este miércoles en
su blog o en su substract esta
información que ha tenido un eco
internacional y que ya de hecho el medio
contexto ha adquirido con derechos de
traducción efectivamente Ángela y como
bien lo decías un reconocido periodista
y muy familiarizado conoce entresijos
del poder en Washington publica un texto
en sus abstract en su blog personal que
parece un poco un capítulo de una novela
de espionaje y que está basado en una
fuente sin embargo conocedora de los
hechos aunque se mantiene anónima y que
se podría resumir este larguísimo texto
de la siguiente forma y es que Estados
Unidos en junio del año pasado por orden
directa del presidente Joe biden mandó a
un grupo de buzos de la marina
estadounidense a que realizara una
operación especial aprovechando unos
ejercicios que realizan la otan
anualmente en el mar Báltico llamados
baltops en este caso baltops para
colocar explosivos en los gasoductos
norstream unos explosivos que la armada
Noruega aliada determinante de Estados
Unidos en este plan hizo detonar tres
meses después en septiembre de 2022 bien
la premisa de esta investigación es
preguntarse por qué Rusia que ha sido
acusada por Estados Unidos no como
responsable de estos sabotajes habría
estado interesada en destruir una
infraestructura tan clave como el norse
no recordemos que estos hay gaseoductos
había dos el norte inmuno y el 2 el 2
nunca llegó a entrar en funcionamiento
pero el nordstream 1 era una
infraestructura clave una gran fuente de
ingresos para Rusia y por otro lado
suponía un vínculo de enorme dependencia
entre Europa y Moscú particularmente
entre Alemania y Moscú Entonces
samuels se pregunta por qué ningún gran
medio de comunicación occidental ha
indagado en este sabotajes ni siquiera
después de las declaraciones de las
autoridades estadounidenses tan en
contra no del norteam como cuando el
mismo Joe biden recordemos en febrero el
7 de febrero de 2022 dijo abiertamente
al lado de olafones que si Rusia invadía
se acabaría en la Stream no bueno a
partir de esta gran pregunta empieza
toda esta investigación
ha sido una pelea internacional
impresionante todo este tema con el nord
Stream Cuáles han sido las reacciones
después de que sale esta publicación que
es por lo menos incendiaria Exactamente
no bien esta publicación en la que se
acusa directamente a Estados Unidos de
estar detrás de estos sabotajes y ha
habido reacción del kremling del
portavoz dimitripes que pide una
investigación internacional y abierta de
los hechos por otro lado la portavoz de
la Casa Blanca Adrián Watson dijo
respondiendo a un email del propio
periodista que esto es falso y una
completa ficción mientras está mejor
portavoz de la Cia en una afirmación
parecida dijo esta afirmación es total y
absolutamente falsa Bueno quién va a
investigar a Estados Unidos rusos y
Estados Unidos es el policía del mundo a
ver entonces hablemos de esta supuesta
planificación que nos narra el
periodista efectivamente bien nos
explica que el interés de Estados Unidos
particularmente de Joe biden con en la
North Stream no con poner punto y final
a esta infraestructura y era a medida
que Rusia va acumulando tropas a lo
largo de 2021 a lo largo de la frontera
con Ucrania dice particularmente en
diciembre de 2021 dos meses Antes de que
los primeros tanques rusos entraran en
Ucrania Jake Sullivan recordemos
consejero de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos convoca una reunión de un
grupo de trabajo entre en las que forman
parte de personas del Estado Mayor de la
defensa de la Cia y de los departamentos
de estado y del tesoro este grupo se
mantiene reuniones periódicas Ultra
secreta con una premisa Clara no según
esta fuente que relata todo lo sucedido
a hertz Y es que Sullivan Jake Sullivan
pretendía que el grupo presentara un
plan para la destrucción de los
gasoductos nordstream y que estos eran
deseos del propio presidente Joe biden
bien la Marina propuso utilizar un
submarino para atacar directamente el
gasoducto la fuerza aérea lanzar bombas
que se detonarán a distancia la Cia dijo
que sea como fuera el plan tenía que ser
un plan encubierto para evitar que se
pudiera rastrear el ataque hacia Estados
Unidos No porque si no sería considerado
un acto de guerra bien el entonces
director de la Cia William burns
autorizó un grupo de trabajo entre los
que casualmente figuraron personas que
conocían de el centro de buceo y
salvamiento de la marina de
estadounidense en Panamá city Florida
bien estos buzos eran solo de la Marina
y no miembros del mando de las fuerzas
especiales nos dice por lo que su
separaciones encubiertas no tenían que
ser comentadas al congreso como si pasa
con operaciones de las fuerzas
especiales Entonces cuando supieron esto
le hacía propuso a este grupo de trabajo
que ya tenían la forma de digamos
detonar de hacer explotar el nordstream
no sin embargo quedaba una última
puntualización y era que las aguas del
mar Báltico están fuertemente
patrulladas por la marina rusa siento
como si me estuviera contando una
secuela de Misión Imposible Así es
Ángela Vamos a entrar en Cómo habría
esta ejecución de esta operación porque
Estados Unidos Aparentemente habría
cooperado con algunos de sus aliados
efectivamente Y Noruega fue un Aliado
clave para Estados Unidos en este plan
según este relato no en Noruega dijeron
era el país ideal para hacer la base de
esta misión porque era un miembro
fundador de la otan enemistad con Rusia
y porque en los últimos años el ejército
estadounidense ha ampliado enormemente
su presencia en Noruega bien una de las
preguntas claves que Noruega respondió
era qué punto Exacto del mar Báltico era
en la mejor para colocar estos
explosivos no la armada Noruega
finalmente apuntó a unas aguas poco
profundas en frente de la isla danesa de
born los noruegos explica este relato
También tenían una solución para la
cuestión crucial de cuando debían
colocarse estos explosivos no finalmente
Encontraron la tapadera que
mencionábamos al principio y es que Como
decíamos cada mes de junio la otan
realiza unos ejercicios de entrenamiento
en el mar Báltico y en este caso se
usarían los ejercicios del mes de junio
de 2022 para que este grupo de
submarinistas de la marina colocara los
explosivos bien en un primer lugar la
idea era que los exclusivos detonarán 48
horas después de estos ejercicios sin
embargo hubo que hacer una última
modificación al plan por orden del Joe
biden y es retrasar un poco la
detonación respecto al momento en que
tenían lugar estos ejercicios de la otan
para que no fuera tan fácilmente
rastreable una causa con la supuesta
consecuencia no Bueno finalmente
el c4 fijado a los gasoductos se activó
mediante una boya de sonar lanzada por
un avión con poca antelación en
septiembre con un avión recordemos de la
fuerza aérea de Noruega este es Pues
digamos
el resultado final este relato no se
colocaban estos explosivos en junio y se
detonaban en septiembre para evitar
digamos que se pudiera relacionar una
cosa con la otra y el resto ya es
historia no Ángela si me permites cerrar
con el párrafo no que acaba resumiendo
toda esta historia dice el 26 de
septiembre de 2022 un avión de la marina
Noruega realizó un vuelo Aparentemente
rutinario y lanzó una boya de sonar la
señal se propagó bajo el agua inicia el
monte al no Stream 2 y luego al nostream
uno pocas horas después se activaron los
explosivos c4 de alta potencia y tres de
las cuatro tuberías quedaron fuera de
servicio a los pocos minutos los charcos
de gas metano que quedaban en los
gasoductos destruidos podían verse
esparciéndose por la superficie del agua
y el mundo se enteró de que había
ocurrido algo Irreversible tremendo
tarea de divulgación la suya Gracias
Rosa gracias